US drops 125 bombs and 85 targets linked
to Iran's revolutionary guard in
devastating air strikes on Iraq and
Syria Biden warns retaliation for drone
attack that killed three soldiers will
continue after long range bombers and
drones hit Middle East uh unilateral
declaration of war or is it just we are
in such a Perpetual state of War they
don't care they're just going to keep
ramping things up and we're going to
spiral out of control and implode or uh
or what there used to be A Wasteland of
our bomb shrapnel it doesn't seem like
it's I it could escalate into a regional
War but they telegraphed it to everyone
that we'd be bombing them so then
everyone that might have been
responsible for the Drone attack is gone
and we're taking out what could be the
places where the drones were um but
we'll see I don't know it's just
interesting to me because I was on the
phone today with a friend who's in uh
Special Forces for the Navy and he was
talking about whatever's going on his
life and then he was saying oh yeah I'm
supposed to deploy this fall and I was
like oh where do where do you think
you're going he's like oh we're getting
back in the Middle East but he says it
the whole thing he didn't say something
specific which makes me think that like
everyone is preparing for intense uh
escalation wasn't there uh something
about the Roman Empire bringing in
foreigners to fight in wars that is part
of the story I believe is it part of the
story does anybody know enough about the
Roman Empire come on men I thought this
all about every single day yeah yeah but
seeing this you know it's perpetual War
the fact that Congress does not approve
of these things anymore we've been at
war in the Middle East for how for for
for decades or longer actually and we're
in Syria Iraq and Syria I mean Iraq I
know right and Syria when I mean of
course it happened with we never left
well with Obama we we go in but my
question is was when when the Iraq War
started there's protest everywhere when
Barack Obama decides to invade Syria
ain't nobody says anything right nothing
Donald Trump comes in tries to get the
troops out they lie to him to keep the
troops in right this is it's it's crazy
that at this point and so now with the
bombing campaign in Iraq and Syria we've
basically got a unilateral declaration
of war on Syria we're attacking Iranian
uh uh uh linked targets whatever that
means it's just there's not going to be
any formal Declaration of a World War
III or expansion of War we're just
slowly walking our way into further and
further escalation on top of that
everyone was has been sharing this video
from December 4th of C-SPAN of senator
Durban saying we should make illegal
immigrants uh uh soldiers we should
bring them in I mean this is C-SPAN
right here dick Durban wants to make it
possible for illegal immigrants to join
the US and I've been getting a bunch of
people messaging me being like that's
exactly how the Roman Empire collapsed
yeah I mean I remember we were we did
IRL the day he did this and uh Kingsley
Cortez was here and we had the same
reaction which was that you can't have a
bunch of people who don't have a tie to
this country come in and fight for you
because ultimately their loyalty is to
the federal government it's not to the
culture or the people or the states and
that is dangerous for the population
that potentially could resist the
federal government it's it's such a
ridiculous suggestion but it's obviously
been on the minds of senators in this
country for a long time again to me that
speaks that they are not ultimately
loyal to the people that they serve
they're they're loyal to power and
controlling the masses yeah it's kind of
like the new form of DACA right this is
the this is the way we get more migrants
into our country we let them serve serve
in our military and then we give them
citizenship say Well done
now you can go to college on the GI Bill
and then you'll be sufficiently roped in
and hopefully support Democrats so do we
see this Administration going around and
rounding up the illegals to and giving
them guns and sending them away and if
they refuse we that Administration
deports them like how does it look I
just don't think they get organized fast
enough right like the reality is that
he's uh going into somewhat of a lame
duck period I mean we've got to November
we expect a wave of executive actions at
the or orders at the end of the year but
like I just don't know the thing is like
one of the reasons that we can't find we
don't know the true number of how many
illegal aliens are here is because they
AR are unregistered so how would the
government you know round up enough of
them they'd have to they'd have to put
out a call and most immigrant groups
like all of the NOS or nonprofits that
support illegal aliens in this country
they always say like if police come to
your door don't answer and you know
resist that so actually there's now a
problem like you can't get them to come
out and the propaganda the propaganda is
crazy
there is this viral uh meme I guess
going around it statistics on crime and
it's like some guy being like just going
to drop this here and it says native
born Americans crime is really high
undocumented immigrants is low and then
immigrants is super low and I'm just
like my guy the crime rate for illegal
immigrants is at least one: one like
quite literally you can't it's
impossible to claim native born citizens
commit more crime as opposed to
quotequote UND documented immigrants
because they started off by committing a
crime which means literally every single
one of them has committed a crime not
every single native born citizen has
committed a crime right they're at 100%
right off the bat that crime doesn't
matter though that that's not a real
crime that's just Civil Disobedience
right but but it is and they exclude it
when it's literally a crime to to
illegally enter the contct illegally
it's a crime we we exclude all kinds of
crime as long as you take down the right
statute or as long as you take you know
storm the right office or desecrate the
right government building if you're
doing the thing we want you to be doing
then I love the meme that they someone
made recently where it's the guy on
January 6 with his feet on the table and
it's not even a funny meme it's just
like six years in prison and then it's
the photo of the guy having gay sex in
the Senate building and it's like no
charges no evidence it's crazy and they
expect everyone to just go along with it
like that's they said there's no
evidence of a crime like there no
evidence of a crime the only reason we
know it happened is because there's a
video that went viral like what are you
talk what if they actually did bring
charges against the people involved and
it actually went to court in Washington
DC would they be convicted cuz you know
how cops work they only charge when they
feel like they can get a conviction
right so I'm so over this man like
there's a there's a video out of Boston
of a bunch of cops standing outside of
the community center in the black
neighborhood where they were housing all
the criminal aliens and there's a black
dude screaming like I can barely afford
to live I work 40 hours a week and I
can't even go to my community center
anymore and the cops are like GTFO and I
just it's just I love it man I tweet F
these these cops scumbags and I get
these conservative Blue Line people
being like Tim it's not the police
officer's fault it's not their fault I'm
like it's dude it's nobody's fault but
the person who committed the crime okay
like some some guy you've never heard of
in an office somewhere you you've never
been to it's the real criminal what are
you talking about I'm watching a guy
work like work with criminal aliens
right here like just how Wild would it
be if somebody is like in the middle of
beating a child and you're like well
hold on hold on who told them to do it
I'm like I don't care dude stop the
person those cops are committing crimes
no but they were told it's not legal
dude and that's where we're currently at
where I just see everything man I think
we got cultural victories and all that
stuff but man it does feel like things
are falling apart because you got every
man for himself mentality it's like
watching the cops not do anything for
the riots like in the city to standing
by meanwhile when they were told to go
arrest people trying to have prayer
service in a park in the city you know
they would do that or yeah arresting the
people wearing the mask or not wearing
Mas it's less likely the people praying
are going to resist I mean they're
expecting the certain people to comply
and I find that that's sort of an insult
I mean we talked about it a couple days
ago on the show but older Generations
are more likely to trust media they're
more likely to trust the federal
government and so in some respects like
the the thing that makes them vulnerable
to being arrested by police is the fact
that they want to comply with the system
they want to be supportive whereas the
police are like well that seems so crazy
over there I'm not sure what we can do
so we just won't like that seems like an
insult to people who are ultimately
trying to live by the rules of Law and
Order yeah so the authorities just go
after the people who are easy targets
yeah because they're afraid of the riots
and they're afraid of the Public Image
can we just like I I know well probably
the bureaucracy within the department
that's usually what kills any sort of
impetus to do something virtuous is I
will lose my job and my wife and kids
are going to suffer and I'm going to
lose my pension and so I'm not going to
do that you should quit them you know
part part of me is glad we haven't seen
a lot of that have we like you lose your
being like I'm done and I think yeah
victim to these pions we've seen a lot
of it actually in New York yeah massive
uh all over the place uh I think you
know at one point a few years ago during
the defund the police Movement we were
looking at more than half of like
departments had seen you know
resignations resignations sick outs yeah
a lot of cops were just like I won't do
this anymore there's even a viral video
where a cop in Seattle is like stopping
at a light and all the activists are
screaming and laughing at him and he's
and he yells you won you won you win I'm
out I quit yeah and then everyone
they're all laughing they're like we got
them I'm just like I was going to say is
I'm glad those the police are refusing
to charge the guys who had the gay sex
in the Senate building cuz I just want
everybody listening to bring that
conversation up to your uh liberal
friends and family members just bring it
right up and when and just like I'm
sorry like when they're like well you
know D I'll be like dude come on there's
a video a viral video literally of a
Democrat Senator staff member getting
banged in the Senate building and they
won't criminally charge him you you you
you want to come to me you want to come
to me and tell me that the machine's not
biased come on have we seen any people
defend that like I haven't evening from
he put out a statement being like I'm
being persecuted because of who I love
and so immediately superimpose me man
that's that's why we can't let it go
that's why because if you notice all of
the prominent leftists will not bring it
up so everybody should just keep talking
about it and it took like 36 hours for
it to puncture through mainstream I
think Fox was one of the first people
reporting it but again it wasn't that
much I mean the story is crazy typically
what they say is sex cells and in case
in this case it's like no one talk
that's wrong kind yeah not this one we
don't like this one we we did the
culture War episode Maybe the day or two
after that happened we on the show
looked it up in the news and there were
no reports on it at all thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net